i don't know if we're allowed to talk
about the fact that there's going to be
a
reunion album coming oh yeah yeah all
right let's talk about that
doughboy cash out so yeah yeah so so
this is the first album and how long our
first project yeah
probably about five five six years yeah
yeah
yeah we working on it's like 90 done it
ain't all the way done
what what what motivated you because
you've been obviously killing it on solo
[ __ ] but like what motivated uh the crew
to come back together man
we always been together like we never
broke up well i mean i'm just as far as
just making
you know like getting in the studio and
making that effort to like actually put
a body of work together
i feel like it just had to be the
perfect time i wanted to be organic
because we even got in there and made
music but it just
it seemed forced i don't know i think
everybody had to get some
some real money it was like that's fair
because we first started rapping and it
was like
it was a hobby it wasn't like we was
making music to make money it was just
like let's get on here and talk some
[ __ ]
it was just a time where we just all had
we was all doing good
everyone's doing good yeah let's come
together let's do this let's do it
because we want to not because we have
to
exactly and that's the best music yeah
100 we made a project